Are you building apps
for business customers?
If yes, I'm going
to tell you how
to take your app to more
than 5 million businesses
by publishing on the
Google Apps Marketplace.
Hi, I'm Apoorv Saxena.
I'm the product manager of
Google Apps Marketplace.
You're going to learn
three things on this video.
First, what is the marketplace?
Why should you publish
on the marketplace?
And how to publish
on the marketplace.
Let's get into details.
Google Apps Marketplace is
the number one preferred
destination for over
$5 million businesses
that use Google
Apps for Business.
Admins come to the
marketplace to discover
high-quality, trusted
apps that they
can install for your domain.
These are apps,
such as FlashPanel,
that have done great integration
with the Google Apps suite.
FlashPanel is an admin
tool that allows customers
to manage and secure
their domains.
Another example is
Mavenlink, which
has done a great integration
with Google Drive, Gmail,
and Calendar.
It's a project management app,
where once a task is completed,
you get a notification in the
email where you can understand
the status of the task.
You can share documents within
Drive using that project
management app and
also set reminders
within Google Calendar.
Admins can discover your
app by going to the website
or by going the admin console.
Once an app is
discovered, the admin
can install your app
to a specific set
of users or all users
within their domain.
So what happens when an app
is installed in a domain?
Once an app is
installed, the app
is accessible by the
users in the domain
through various touch points
within the Google App suite.
For example, here, a Gmail
user can access your app
by clicking on the App
Launcher drop down menu.
Here, for example, if the
user clicks on Insightly,
he is single-signed
on into Insightly
right there from
the App Launcher.
Users can also access their
app from the Drive Create menu.
Here, an app such as Lucidpress,
a design and layout app,
has done an
integration with Drive.
Once the app is installed,
users can directly
launch Lucidpress from
Drive and also store
design documents in Drive.
They can even open Gmail
attachments using Lucidpress.
You might say, all
this sounds great,
but how big is the marketplace?
And what is its reach?
How about 200 million?
That's the number of seats that
our customers have installed
since the launch of Marketplace.
And this number is
increasing rapidly.
But that's not all.
Developers who have been
successful on the Marketplace
tell us Marketplace offers a
truly differentiated experience
than any other
distribution channel.
It drives 4x more
paid conversion
than any other
distribution channel.
It drives 2x more engagement
than other channels.
And it also drives
1.5x, in some cases,
of customer lifetime
value for our customers.
So let's look into how to
publish on the marketplace.
To publish on the
Marketplace, you
need to do first
prepare your app.
You need to create a project
in the Google Apps developer
console.
In this project, you need to
configure the Google Apps SDK
and other associated
Google Apps SDK that you
need to build your integration.
For example, if you're
building a drive indication,
you need to enable
Drive SDK and also
ask for the Drive API access.
Once you have done
these two things,
your app is ready
for publishing.
Publishing involves
three main steps.
You are to prepare your app,
manifest and associated assets.
Then you have to configure
in the Chrome Web Store
the publishing settings.
And then you have to
submit an app review form.
Let's go into the details of
each of these steps briefly.
Publishing the app
manifest tells us
a little more information
about your app.
This many app manifests should
look very similar to the Chrome
Web Store App
manifest if you have
published on the
Chrome Web Store.
The only difference is the
domain installable container,
as you see highlighted
in this slide.
This tells us that you
are ready to publish
your app to the Google Apps
for Business customers.
Once you have built
this app manifest
and uploaded the
corresponding app icons,
you now need to go to the
Chrome Web Store Developer
console, upload
this information.
Also add other details,
like app descriptions,
screenshots, URLs.
And also select the
necessary category
where you want this
app to be listed,
and region and the language.
Once you have done
that, you're now
ready for the last step, which
is filling out the app review
form.
We use this form to
understand what integrations
you are building and to make
sure you're following the best
practices as listed on the
Marketplace Documentation page.
We also test out the
integration to make
sure the user
experience is seamless.
We also use this step to
prevent any abuse and spam
of the publishing process.
This step usually takes no
more than two weeks for us
since this time of you
submitting the review form.
Once the app is
published, your app
is now visible to more
than 5 million businesses,
as I mentioned.
But that's not all.
There is one more step.
You can also drive more
installs for your app right
from your website by
clicking on the Integrate
with Google button.
This is a button that we
launched two months back.
It helps admins directly
start the install process
from your website without
ever going to the Google Apps
Marketplace.
For more information on how to
do integration with Integrate
with Google, please visit
the Marketplace Documentation
webpage.
The webpage also
provides you more details
about how to be successful
on the Marketplace.
In summary, Marketplace is
the preferred destination
for more than 5
million businesses
that are using Google
Apps for Business
for finding business apps.
It is also driving great, high
quality installs for your app.
And also, we have
done a great job
of providing three easy steps
to publish on the marketplace.
So if you are a
business app developer
and if you haven't published
on the Marketplace,
what are you waiting for?
Go out there, code,
and we would love
to see you on the
Google Apps Marketplace.
Thank you.